- Medellin, de plus en plus,
veut vou
de cacher que c'est encore
la ville de tous les dangers.
Luis Fernandoesesesesesesesese.
Il ne peut se déplacer
sans ses deux véhicules blindés.
Le sien, avec comme chauffeuraru
corps, et un autre a ses côtés.
Collée derrière, une camionnette
avec trois autres gardest t t te
dans le trafic de Medellin.
Cette grande ville est
bien moins violente queemememem,
mais elle reste dangereuse
Luis Fernando, qui préside d ds
de la personne CORPADES, a lan
il y a 10 ans le site Analyse
Urbaine, qui publie tout cququqe
les citoyens de Medelldudududu
département d'Antioquia, ce qui
lui vaut beaucoup d'
Medatatatattire beaucoup de
touristes. Ville chaleureuse au
Moderne, avec son métro, qui aêa
13 une attraction touristique,
Tout comme le Ba
que Pablo Escobar a fait
construire poupapapapauvres.
On trouve de tout à Medellin
et avant t
en marché libre, qui gangrène
plusiearararartiers.
De quoi faire la fête.
La
Cocaïne, fête totale
et tourisme sexuel, femmes,
hommes, garçons, petitesou tous.
Ceci est un vrai bor
Pas le plus grand bordel
du monde, nous ava
Luis Fernando il y a quatre ans,
mais le moins
Alors, qu'y a-t-il ici
et le crime transnational?
(en espagnol)
Un paradis pour toutes
les mafias du monde : danoise,
hollandaise, canadienne...
(en espagnol)
Il y a la puissante mafia
il a dénoncé la présence
il y a quatre ans - ce qui lui
vaut les menaces actuelles -init
par les autorités. Les cartels
de Sinaloa et de Jalisco
Nouvelle Génération contrôlentïe
par le Pacifique.
Ils travaillent en concurrence
ou, parf
locales. Le clan du Golfe, dont
l'extrn n n n du chef Otoniel
vers les États-Unis a provoqué
nord et une confrontation entre
mémémémée et les producteurs de
coca. Le ministre de la défense
survolant l'Antioquia pour
annoncer la fin proche
du Clan du Golfe.
Non seulement le Clan du Golfe ,
mais il n'existe pas vraiment
à une puissante association
de mafias : les Autodéfenses
gaïanistes de Colombie,
groupes paramilitaires.
Les AGC se heurtent parfois
de Envigado. Littéralement
"le bureau d'Envigado",
un quartier de Medellin favori
une organisation mystérieuse
du crime, infiltrée dans
tous les milieux, dont ondididi.
(en espagnol)
La criminalité imprègne toutes,
le pouvoir politique et aussi
économique de ce pays.
Assassinats politiquesrerererert
l'héritage de Pablo Escobar.
(en espagnol)
Un héritage bâtintntntnt
des décennies, incrusté dansmbme
Felipe Tascón confirme.
Il y a 5 ans, la Colombielalala
cocaïne du monde, avec le Pérou
et la Bolivie pour le reste.
Maintenant, elle produit 75 % d.
(en espagnol)
Spécialiste de l'économie
du narcotrafic, Felipe se baseo:
1230 tonnes de cocaïne
rapportent plus de 17 milliards
de dollars par an à l'économieat
intérieur brut.
(en espagn
Cet argent
toutes les institutions.
vraiment qui veut sa peau :leles
qui les protègent?
(en espagnol)
Nous ne savons pas qui
est le plus danger
notre sécurité et celle de notre
famille. Famille e e e essaie
de faire sortir du pays le plus
vite possibl
Colombie, un État narco? Felipe
Tascón ne hésitation.
(en espagnol)
Le combattre? Un défi
président de la Colombie